you just love these like hypotheticals
this is just like I don't know when men
have
like when just men have just like is
this the most like bro conversation I
think it is you know well I think I
think I I bet they're talking about
girls it's like you would die
in I I I think I've had this
conversation a few Fair few times with
other fellow men I think I yearned to
just be in a survival situation where
I'm forced to just learn the basics yeah
just learn how to just do everything
myself
okay as a guy okay okay shopping right
okay do you go do you when you go
shopping do you know exactly what you
need and go straight for it or do you
ever go shopping and you're like I don't
know I I just want to go shopping I
don't leave the house unless I have a
written list of [__] I need to
buy you know I
mean I'm pretty sure that's a dude thing
right like it's like it's like I don't
understand like Ary who's just like yeah
I'm just going to go out shop do you
want to come and I'm like yeah sure what
are you buying just like I don't know
I'm like what do you mean you don't know
yeah I mean I don't like to buy things
unless I need it but I do understand
that sometimes you're like man I just
want an excuse to go outside and
sometimes just checking stores is nice
and sometimes you see something you're
like man I didn't know I wanted that but
I no but I find that kind of stuff as I
am as I'm going through the list of
things that I need like I would happen
to find something where I'm like oh
that's actually kind of cool and I would
buy that sometimes like like go to a
store this is mentality why I have no
goddamn clothes though [__] go out to
[__] clothes I'm like I have
perfectly good clothes right now that is
true and that's probably why I need to
update my dra as well and Joey Joey
instead of just going shopping just made
his own [__] clothing companies
instead of just being like I was so sick
and tired of every time I would go out
shopping there would be a list of [__]
that I needed and then just right next
to the supermarket there would just be
kind of like a cool clothing store and
I'm like I'll go check it out cuz I've
got some time and I was just like damn
I'm wasting like so much time in money
on this [__] I'm going just do it myself
men be like I'd rather just make an
entire [__] brand and clothing
company than just go out shopping for
myself I just realized how dumb I am I
read this [__] Spanish beer out on a
German accent
before it's actually not bad as well
it's not bad nice Bain this is much
better than the other [__] very good we
had this moment with uh daus uh when
when he was in England where I was just
showing them around I was it was like me
uh DUS uh Sydney and Emily and I we were
just going to like show them around
Brighton and just have like a nice time
and I remember um they just wanted like
I think uh Sydney wanted to pick up
something in like the mall uh so we went
to the mall and as soon as we go in the
mall like Sydney goes into like the
clothing shop that she needs to go to to
pick up something and then Emily sees
like a clothing shop that she wants to
go to and uh she spends like a lot of
time going through like different
clothes and everything like that and
then we had a moment where Emily gets
some clothes that she just happened to
see when we were just out and about
right right and the girls are like oh do
you want to continue like looking at
stores and we were like if we're going
shopping as as like the partner I need
to like mentally prepare myself to go to
like have like the shopping day you know
you know what I mean I don't know if
this is a me thing I totally what you
mean yeah like like I I thought we were
just going to go out and explore if
we're doing a shopping day like as a guy
I need to mentally prepare yeah I don't
really want to go shopping unless I'm in
the mood yeah yeah it's like oh I'm
about to be the luggage
carrier God damn and then like daus had
the exact same reaction to me and I'm
like is this a guy thing where totally
if we go shopping we we like okay here's
the thing we're fine having a shopping
day we just need some time to like
mentally prepare to have a shopping day
we you can't just like spring it on us
like we can't just go out and suddenly
we're going to go shopping we need to
like go out to be like okay it's not as
spontaneous as it is for girls right
yeah yeah with girls it's like you don't
even have to second guess it it's like
you know what I got some time uh you
know my girlfriend is here with me let's
just [__] go shopping whatever but
for the guys it's like all right let me
think in the recesses of my brain what
am I missing in my life that I need
right now
let's go and if I'm and then the moment
you buy that thing you're like we're
going
home I mean like yeah yeah I got
everything I wanted that's I don't have
to look at anything else I thought for
me I was mentally scared because as a
kid my mom would always take me to like
the car boot sales basically garage
sales but like English version sure and
I would go to like the one table that I
always knew was there that had like kind
of like games and some DVDs I I go to
that one table and I'm like Mom I'm done
and my mom would spend like 3 hours
there looking for antique stuff and I'm
like I'm I'm I'm ready to go home now
Mom I'm ready to go home and I never
understood my dad until I got older who
we he take her to the car boot sell and
he just stay in the car the entire time
no the the the correct thing would have
been to leave come back later yeah like
just tell me roughly when you're done
and I'll I'll come and pick you up I'm
going to go home and sit on the couch be
comfortable yeah and I never understood
that Dad energy until I realized now
that I'm older and I'm like oh I would
have done the same thing yeah totally I
had a cold sweat the other day thinking
about a decision I made when I was
younger and I wish I could go back and
slap myself
what I really wanted uh to get Twilight
Phantom princess on the Wii and I
remember I I gave I I traded in like 30
[__] did you call it Twilight Phantom
princess do you mean Twilight Princess
you made I was like is there a Twilight
game called Phantom princess TL princess
[__] what the [__] Twilight Phantom
princess the be be this is 7% be be
hitting
me uh Twilight Princess I was like damn
they made a Twilight game on the Wii
this Twilight Princess right it's
twilight princess Legends of Twilight
Princess where the I think Phantom
Hourglass and Twilight Princess yeah
[__] okay yeah uh Twilight Princess on
the Wii and uh I traded in like [__]
20 GameCube games and a bunch of like Mr
gaming watch Game Boy games oh my God
and I think it was like now if you
bought them all I think it'd be worth
like 400 bucks oh easily especially the
GameCube games I gave in I'm like [__] I
think I traded in like Super Mario
Sunshine smash BRS all the [__] just for
one damn game dude Super Mario Brothers
and Smash Bros by itself would like rack
you at least a 100 bucks just with those
two games in Japan right now I had
Luigi's Mansion too I think that's worth
like that was even worth more oh yeah
cuz no one [__] bought that game in
Europe I did yeah I know it's rare
though it's actually it's worth a lot
well it's worth more than it was when
you bought it oh [__] I still have
mine condition I just I just wake up
like why did you trade it in just wait a
minute it's crazy to think that like the
value of Nintendo games just go up but
like well that's what happens when you
don't allow people to buy your games
yeah uh play [__] Rolexes but it's
just like artificial SC scarcity dude
yeah am I an idiot I can't [__] open
this you good man I don't I don't have
any fingernails thank you you never do I
know I don't think in the history of
friend I've never I've like you always
have trouble open this is the one thing
I wish I could get real I get my [__]
nails to like golom mask levels and I'm
like I guess I should cut rid of them
[__] scraping my inside my butthole
when I'm wiping myself I mean so like I
should cut that's how you get
hemorrhoids no I I I just like letting
them grow out because I love the
satisfaction of like seeing it like the
difference it's like a before and after
for Like a Pimp My Ride with for my
hands that's like I'm the same but with
toenails nice M like with with my
toenails CU with with my nails it's
really annoying because you see them on
a daily basis but
toenails you you can't see them but they
get way thicker than like the
fingernails how do you fight the urge to
to clip your toenails the correct like
cuz I you know you're supposed to CL
clip your toils just straight be like
flat yeah [__] off no you're not you
didn't know no apparently that's what
you're supposed to wa you didn't know
this you know this right no I know this
wait wait wait what they're not supposed
to be curved
should be flat [__] off no at least
that's that's how I was this your first
time hearing this yeah this is genuinely
this just this is genuinely the first
time I'm so your fingernails totally
fine to do that but your your toenail
should be cut like at like a like
completely like
straight it's checking right
now all right get those little grippers
out let's see these I just cut them like
literally two days ago yeah no you
shouldn't do that that's how you get
ingrown toil that's how you get ingrown
toenails yeah you know what I've got
ingrown toenails for my entire life I've
I've never had an ingrown chail did you
cut them straight yeah I just cut them
straight but I I always have that urge
to like I want to clip off the edges
yeah I've done that as a kid and it was
uh didn't go well so the because the way
that it grows for some reason on your
feet it it the if it's straight it'll
grow outwards like that but if you
already have it like that it will grow
like you know if you think about the
shape the way it grows yeah cuz it
naturally is going to curve outward well
I don't cut it like too deep which is
that pretty [__] deep there's there's
no nail no nail left I've gone pretty
[__] deep on it kind that's kind of
how my toenails look as well what yeah
cuz I I like I don't know okay okay when
you say straight I just follow the
straight yeah yours is like dead
straight see that's that's straight
right there I think you just have
straight toes no
no I think you just have straight to my
to straight no gone I just cut them
straight what mean okay okay it looks
weird it looks weird when you cut but I
swear I follow the line I follow the
line no you're not supposed to you're
not supposed to no not on your toenails
did you not know this no stop doing
it you don't want an INR on toenail that
shit's hurt I know it's had it before
yeah well I thought everyone knew this
and nav's checking now too everyone in
the off checking the toes right now you
know this I thought this common
knowledge I mean I knew about
it so where where did you hear this from
I just heard it a bunch you're not
supposed to not supposed to cut your
turnils that way [__] you [__] your
turnils too oh
yeah cuz Southeast Asian thing Kai do
you know about this no okay okay thank
me did you know about this but I know
like the poor people rich people what
what oh God wait what did she say she
said she knows the poor people of rich
people feet thing what you about your Fe
oh
yeah
can hold on okay wait wait wait on are
are you saying that if you just look at
you never explained to me okay let let
me show you what me sent me man like I'm
just chilling one day is it is it the is
it the palm reading thing is it the
same I'm I'm just chilling I'm I'm just
chilling one day right and then me sends
me me sends me this image and says and
asks me what what feet do you have a
Roman foot a square foot a Greek foot or
an Egyptian foot I have who the [__] is
a square foot I have I have a Greek foot
I have a friend like you have I have the
Roman foot you have a Roman foot no no
no cuz it's like curved no yours is like
straight and yours is kind of like that
so yours is kind of like in between a
Roman and a Greek foot I'll take it
mine's mine's straight up a Greek foot
my my second toe just [__] jots out I
have like between a so what's the point
of
this wait so wait wait so what do you
never told me what what what mine means
so is it your middle toe is long no my
second toe is really long so I have a I
have a Greek foot you have a joyous life
okay this is I have a joyous life what
the you might as well start reading my
[__] Palms at that point like it's
the same thing what about your feet CER
uh his is like in between a Greek and
second my next one to the the Roman one
is more close yeah he's like Roman as
well so it's like three the big one and
the second one and the third one are the
same no no it's it's slightly a triangle
but not by a lot slightly a triangle oh
you have a romantic life you have a
romantic life apparently sheh
Dam this is copium of the highest order
this is what people do when they're
board yeah